er und wir haben nicht schlecht gestaunt
vor wenigen stunden was putins
propaganda tv gerade mit unserem bild
reportern macht hier schauen sie da
knöpft sich der chef der oper kann das
von putin
unseren kriegsreporter bevor der seit
monaten so faktisch so wie er sagt nicht
aus der ukraine resona und der hier
putins chef propagandist der redet über
björn dort die ganze zeit dieser putin
propagandisten in seiner russisch zu 60
minuten bezeichnet auch unser gehirn als
nazi immer wieder zeigt dieser jewgeni
poppe auf unseren reporter da im einsatz
bei den deutschen panzerhaubitzen und
verleugnete ihnen das ist vor einem
millionenpublikum anlass dafür ist diese
und reportage von jan stritzel der
berichtet er aus der ost ukraine vom
einsatz der deutschen kanzler bis 2000
der mittlerweile im alltagseinsatz dort
sind an der front in der ukraine die
deutschen nazi faschisten haubitzen so
heißt dass man ihn für den tvg gern wird
immer immer wieder ebenfalls als nazi
bezeichnet bild chef johannes boje bei
uns im studio also unser bild reporter
und sabin dort verleumdet im russen tvm
putin tv was bedeutet das für björn was
bedeutet das aber für bild guten morgen
erstmal also es ist natürlich ein
sagenhafter angriff auf die
pressefreiheit da muss man sagen das
sind wir von der fall der diktatur in
moskau mittlerweile natürlich gewöhnt
trotzdem wichtig dass auch noch mal
ausdrücklich zu sagen im westen sind wir
nicht so hier lassen wir journalisten
und zur arbeit machen das haben die
russen nicht mehr drauf das wollen sie
nicht andererseits natürlich auch ein
sagenhaftes lob für björn für seine
fantastische arbeit er ist der erste und
der einzige der diese panzerhaubitzen
2000 die deutschland jetzt ja endlich
geschickt hat wirklich im einsatz auch
begleiten konnte und so wie sich die
russen darüber aufregen ist das
eigentlich ein großes lob für unsere
arbeit das heißt du siehst so ein
angriff er eigentlich als bestätigung
vielleicht gar sogar als motivation dass
wir unsere arbeit journalistinnen und
journalisten genauso fortführen ganz
klar patricia es ist ja so dass
journalismus versucht immer neutral zu
sein und versucht eigentlich keine
gegnerschaft zu dem aufzubauen über das
wir berichten aber hier ist die lage
ebenso klar die russen wollen hier gar
kein journalismus die russen nahmen den
journalismus abgeschafft es ist nur noch
propaganda und dass wir dann eben
kritisiert werden zeigt dann ja doch
schon dass wir die gegner sind und in
dem fall in diesem einen fall natürlich
dann auch dass wir einen guten job
machen weil es hier keine gegnerschaft
ist über inhalte ist das richtig ist das
richtig sondern ist eine gegnerschaft
journalismus versus propaganda und je
mehr die russen auf uns auf bild
einprügeln und das tun sie ja schon seit
monaten mit björn das ist jetzt einfach
ein neuer höhepunkt umso mehr versichert
ist mir eigentlich dass wir einen guten
job machen gestern habe ich in report
bekommen der gerade in russland
rumgereicht wird von einer organisation
die dort medienarbeit im westen
auswertet und da stand absatz weise was
bild alles macht ja also aus der
russischen sicht aus der aus der sicht
der folter diktatur wie schlimm das ist
dass wir so gute reporter haben dass wir
in der ukraine vor ort sind dass wir ein
russisch sprachigen programm aus
hanstedt und das ist natürlich für mich
liest sich das wie ein lob also vielen
dank an die duma an die propagandisten
da wir haben das gehört wir nehmen das
zur kenntnis großes lob für bonn
stritzel und alle unsere reporterinnen
und reporter in der ukraine weil bild
eben auch auf russisch sendet das hast
du gerade nochmal gesagt johannes ganz
wichtig auch deswegen offenbar putin tv
und putins chef propagandist kräftig
genervt von uns von unseren reportern
von unserer berichterstattung dort aus
der ukraine dank johannes wir müssen
aber noch einmal auch über gas gerd
sprechen denn auch der hat viele genervt
wieder weil er sich groß zu wort
gemeldet hat am gestrigen tag über den
stern in einem jahr waren besserwisser
interview dort mit der überschrift warum
soll ich mich eigentlich entschuldigen
er schauen wir mal reine in dieses
interview der feinen ein paar gute putin
propaganda setzte kann man sagen schon
der titel allein sehen sie hier warum
soll ich mich entschuldigen aber dann
hatte auch noch folgende idee
m2 in betrieb nehmen die einfachste
lösung wäre die pipelines weise sagte in
betrieb zu nehmen mit beiden nord
stream-pipeline es gäbe es kein
versorgungsproblem für die deutschen ist
konnte das ein oder andere eigene
geschäftliche
bei der aussage eine rolle gespielt
haben bei gas gerd jedenfalls hat sich
der ukrainische staatspräsident selensky
auch zum gas gerhard geäußert jetzt
zumindest indirekt seinen namen nicht in
den mund nehmen aber dass die aussage
von vladimir selensky dem ukrainischen
staatspräsidenten zu diesen zitaten von
gas gerd
das verhalten von gerhard schröder ist
einfach ekelhaft ekelhaft wenn ehemalige
führer großer staaten mit europäischen
werten für russland arbeiten denn
russland ist im krieg mit genau diesen
werten
dass also genau diese werte die er dort
beschreibt und schröder der gleichzeitig
darüber spricht dass russland
verhandlungsbereit sei also eher den dir
das handlungs spektrum so erweitert das
ist eigentlich januar johannes pro jahr
unser chefredakteur noch bei uns im
studio an uns liegt dieses verhandlungs
gebot dann auch mal aufzunehmen und
einzugehen wie findest du das wie
empfindest du dass das ein als kanzler
solche worte die auch in der ukraine für
so ein ekel sorgen für so ein
unverständnis sorgen rice hat patrizia
ist es würdelos es ist wirklich
beschämend und wir haben hier einen
ehemaligen deutschen bundeskanzler bei
dem wir uns mittlerweile dieselben
fragen stellen müssen wie bei einem
25-jährigen nazi wie bei einer 30
jährigen linksextremisten bis wohin gilt
die meinungsfreiheit wie muss man die
äußerungen bewerten ja das ist etwas was
man aushalten muss meine wir kennen das
alle von der meinungsvielfalt in der
demokratie aber dass ein ehemaliger
deutscher bundeskanzler sich zu sowas
hinreißen lässt
ist einfach unterirdisch es ist wirklich
beschämend und ich bin nur froh darüber
dass gerhard schröder eigentlich
weitgehend auch aus dem diskurs
herausgedrängt wurde alle wissen auch
dass gerhard schröder sehr sehr sehr
viel trinkt ich rede regelmäßig mit
menschen die in sehr gut kennen die
beschreiben das immer wieder viele wein
lieferungen der wein wird früh am tag
aufgemacht so wird es mir berichtet und
ich denke das ordnet eigentlich ganz gut
ein wie man das ernst zu nehmen hat
nämlich gar nicht ich finde auch die
medien haben hier eine verantwortung die
frage es gibt man gerhard schröder noch
eine plattform ja oder nein er ist
nichts anderes als rheingas lobbyist als
ein lobbyist von putin der hier die
regierungsarbeit der russischen
kriegsverbrecher übernimmt und macht
muss man halt dann auch genauso bewerten
und vielleicht auch nicht weiter ernst
nehmen kann ist wo in vielen herzlichen
dank für diese einordnung danke auch für
deinen besuch hier im studio danke
[Musik]